vie de quartier. Je suis allé le
rencontrer. Mais vous allez
voir, il n'y a pas de bons et
méchants dans l'histoire. Il y a
un problème extrêmement complexe
que l'on doit regarder en face.
Monsieur Marcotte, bonjour.
- Bonjour, monsieur Roy!
- Alors nous sommes à côté
du Royal Versailles,
on voit la Place Versailles.
Vous êtes dans un groupe
de citoyens qui jugez que
ça n'a pas été une bonne idée
d'amener des itinérants,
des sans-abri ici. Qu'est-ce que
ça a changé dans votre vie,
dans votre quartier?
CHRISTIAN MARCOTTE, résident,
Mercier - Hochelaga-Maisonneuve
- Bien moi, j'habite le quartier
ici depuis 20 ans et puis du
jour lendemain, on a transplanté
un problème qui était
plus présent au centre-ville
de Montréal dans un quartier
résidentiel et familial.
Donc c'est certain que du jour
au lendemain, les vols, la
sollicitation, la consommation
de drogue à aire ouverte,
ramasser des seringues au parc,
ce sont toutes des choses
qu'on ne connaissait pas
dans le quartier.
- Moi, ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est qu'est-ce que la Ville,
qu'est-ce que l'arrondissement
vous dit? Comment on gère
ce problème-là qui est réel?
Est-ce qu'il y a des élus
qui sont venus vous voir?
- Non, les élus... il y a
une pétition qui a été déposée
au conseil d'arrondissement
le 7 septembre dernier, puis
ça n'a pas été un sentiment
agréable pour les résidents
de voir que notre propre maire
nous faisait sentir mal d'être
méchants ou de ne pas comprendre
cette problématique-là.
- Est-ce qu'il y a des gens
qui sont déchirés en disant :
"On ne veut pas passer pour
des sans-coeur parce qu'il faut
les loger, les sans-abri,
il faut trouver une façon..."
Donc vous, ce dilemme-là,
l'avez-vous vécu?
- Je l'ai vécu, je l'ai vécu
et à un moment donné, j'ai dû
accepter que ce n'est pas
d'être sans-coeur de demander à
ce que les résidents reprennent
leur place dans un quartier
et qu'ils soient entendus,
et qu'ils aient une voix réelle.
- Monsieur Marcotte, c'est
très clair, merci beaucoup
de nous avoir parlé.
- Merci beaucoup, monsieur Roy.
Ça fait plaisir.
- Karine Boivin-Roy, bonjour.
- Bonjour, monsieur Roy.
- Vous êtes candidate ici,
à la mairie d'arrondissement.
Vous êtes consciente du problème
que M. Marcotte, dont
M. Marcotte nous parlait.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait? À partir
du moment où ils arrivent dans
un quartier, est-ce que ce n'est
pas illusoire de penser qu'il
n'aura pas des effets autour?
KARINE BOIVIN-ROY, candidate
à la mairie, Ensemble Montréal
- Je vais vous répéter
ce qu'on répète depuis le mois
de décembre, parce qu'on avait
proposé, l'opposition officielle
avait proposé une motion au
conseil municipal dans laquelle
ce qu'on demandait, c'était
qu'il y ait des hôtels qui
soient réquisitionnés, mais bien
sûr avec un nombre d'occupants
qui est raisonnable. Est-ce que
le chiffre magique, ce sera
30, 40, 50? Les experts nous
le diront, mais assurément, on
ne peut pas avoir 130 personnes
qui arrivent soudainement
dans un quartier avec
des problématiques particulières
et s'attendre qu'il n'y ait pas
d'impact sur les citoyens
riverains. Ça, c'est la première
chose, monsieur Roy. La deuxième
chose, c'est qu'il faut trouver
des installations alternatives,
il faut trouver d'autres lieux
dans un souci d'équité
territoriale.
Troisième des choses, ça prend
un plan de cohabitation qui est
très structuré, qui est réel,
qui répond aux besoins
adéquatement et qui a
les ressources.
- Quand les citoyens ont demandé
une rencontre, quand il y a eu
une rencontre avec
l'agrandissement...
- Bonsoir tout le monde.
L'arrondissement de Mercier -
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve...
- ... Il n'y avait pas d'élus
apparemment. Ça vous choque pas,
ça?
- Oui, tout à fait.
Dans Mercier - Hochelaga-
Maisonneuve, on ne peut pas dire
qu'on manque d'expérience après
18 mois de pandémie. On a eu
le centre Pierre-Charbonneau,
on a maintenant le Royal
Versailles, on a le YMCA, on a
eu le campement de Notre-Dame,
le boisé Steinberg. J'oserais
croire que l'administration, à
la fois celle locale et la ville
centre, ont tiré des leçons
de ça et qu'on est capable
d'en arriver avec des solutions
pérennes et non simplement dire:
"Bien, oui, on constate que
l'itinérance est exacerbée
depuis la pandémie, mais ah!
L'itinérance, c'est
la compétence de Québec."
Je m'excuse, mettre en place
plan de cohabitation, contacter
les citoyens en amont, les
concertées, les aviser de ce qui
va se passer pour qu'il puisse
être préparé à cette nouvelle
réalité là,, c'est à la fois une
manière d'intégrer de manière
harmonieuse dans un quartier ce
qui va se passer.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Nathalie Goulet, vous êtes
responsable de ce dossier
important de l'itinérance à
Montréal le comité exécutif. Le
Royal Versailles, est-ce que ce
n'est pas l'exemple qu'on ne
doit pas suivre? Mettre des
gens-là de ne pas consulter les
gens dans le quartier et se
retrouver avec des citoyens qui
n'en peuvent plus?
NATHALIE GOULET, inclusion soc.,
arr. d'Ahuntsic-Cartierville
- Écoutez, je comprends très
bien la surprise des citoyens
qui vivent dans un quartier
résidentiel qui, jour lendemain,
doivent vivre avec sans une
ressource qui accueillait 100 ou
120 personnes et c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille actuellement, on
est tous mobilisés à la
cohabitation sociale, autour de
la ressource. Mais Écoutez, on
est en pandémie, la pandémie
depuis 18 mois à jeter dans la
rue beaucoup de personnes, on
fait face à une augmentation
très, très grande du nombre de
personnes en situation
d'itinérance à Montréal et, par
ailleurs, nos refuges
traditionnels que l'on connaît
ont perdu à cause des mesures
sanitaires 30 % de leur
capacité.
- Mais dans cette...
Vous parlez de cohabitation.
Dans la cohabitation, on a
l'impression que les citoyens
ordinaires ont été oubliés.
- Non, pas du tout.
C'est quelque chose...
- Bien, il y en a 1000
qui ont signé une pétition!
Ils se sentent oubliés, ils ne
se sont pas entendus comme
si on leur disait : "Mon Dieu,
vous n'êtes pas généreux, vous!
Vous refusez des sans-abri."
Comme si on leur faisait
la morale un peu.
- Je comprends tout à fait
leur suprise actuellement et
ils ne connaissent pas toutes
les ressources de leur quartier,
tout ça, c'est très nouveau.
Il y a très peu de lieux
disponibles actuellement aussi.
La Ville est en soutien et
c'est le réseau de la santé,
c'est très important de le dire,
le gouvernement du Québec qui
est responsable de financer
ces ressources temporaires là.
La Ville est en soutien et c'est
pour ça qu'on travaille avec eux
la cohabitation.
- Madame Goulet, vous êtes
résidente dans ce coin-là,
vous allez au parc, vous voyez
une seringue, vous voyez
des gens au métro Radisson qui
harcèlent vos jeunes qui vont
à l'école. Vous dites quoi
concrètement à ces citoyens-là?
- Écoutez, il y a des séances
d'informations qui sont faites
actuellement.
- Oui, mais ça ne change pas
la réalité, ça!
- Ça change, ça finit par
changer la réalité quand
on travaille ces enjeux-là
tout autour et c'est ça
qu'on fait actuellement.
Il faut des ressources, il faut
que les gens connaissent
les organismes communautaires
de leur quartier. S'ils trouvent
une seringue, par exemple, par
terre, ils savent qui appeler
pour venir régler ce problème-
là...
- Oui, mais là, on est dans
votre quartier, madame Goulet,
et je veux dire, c'est
un problème complexe, je suis
d'accord avec vous. On est dans
votre quartier, il y aurait
des seringues... Je ne sais pas
si vous avez des enfants d'âge
à aller au parc...
- Tout à fait.
- Mais s'il y avait des
seringues; quand même que je
connais comme papa l'organisme
qui s'occupe de ça, ça ne change
pas qu'on ne veut pas ça.
Il doit y avoir un contrat
social avec ceux qui viennent
dans des quartiers, dire :
il y a un respect aussi
à y avoir. Non?
- Oui, et ça se travaille
avec les personnes en situation
d'itinérance aussi pour prévenir
les incivilités. Ça, ce sont des
choses que les organismes qui
sont des experts en intervention
sociale sur le terrain font
avec les personnes en situation
d'itinérance tout le temps.
- Dernière question :
les citoyens qui s'inquiètent,
c'est quand même un élément dans
l'équation politique important,
c'est un élément, il faut tenir
compte des citoyens quand
ils élèvent la voix et
qu'ils disent... Or, il y a eu
une rencontre et aucun élu
de votre côté n'est allé
le 30 septembre.
C'était des administrateurs
de l'arrondissement, c'était
des policiers. Est-ce que
le rôle de l'élu, ce n'est pas
de faire face à cette grogne-là
et de leur expliquer?
- Les élus... les élus sont
en constante discussion
avec les partenaires locaux.
Ils sont très conscients de
ce qui se passe actuellement et
on travaille aussi comme jamais
avec le réseau de la santé et
des services sociaux, qui sont
responsables de ces ressources-
là, pour les pérenniser
correctement avec des plans,
vous avez raison, il faut
des plans solides, à long terme.
Mais actuellement, on est encore
dans l'urgence malheureusement.
- Merci, on va suivre ça.
C'est un gros dossier important.
Merci beaucoup.
- Tout à fait. Merci b